bonjour bienvenue dans cet autre cas dit
notre invité ce matin hervé honoré
bonjour bonjour versant caruge et
bonjour aux auditeurs de martine combien
vous êtes le nouveau président du
conseil des prud'hommes vous avez été
élu avec vos vice présidents des cinq
sections de ce conseil le 12 janvier
dernier
vous êtes âgé de 54 ans vous êtes le
gérant du groupe
hyacinthe et on le rappelle comme c'est
la règle en alternance la présidence
donc du conseil des prud'hommes en 2021
est assurée par un élu issu du collège
des employeurs vous étiez d'ailleurs
seul candidat en lice
et vous avez été élu à l'unanimité et
puis enfin on va préciser que vous
prenez la succession de franck raymond
hains qui était représentant des
salariés issus du syndicat de la cdmt et
qui lui devient maintenant le vice
président de cette juridiction
prud'homale en martinique voilà alors à
titre un peu plus personnelle hervé
honoré
pourquoi avoir voulu et accepter cette
présidence du conseil des prud'hommes de
la martinique alors peut-être pour toi
toi raisons essentielles la première
c'est que j'ai pu suivre deux grandes
écoles au niveau national grâce à un
financement qui s'appelle prêts
d'honneur et et même si ce prêt en bon
ces lignes je me sens redevable du
territoire de la collectivité martinique
et chaque fois qu'on peut contribuer à
faire que sur des domaines où on peut
faire avancer le génie 3 je serai
toujours volonté la deuxième raison
c'est que les prud'hommes ont une
exception beauté de française c'est
qu'on permet en premier instance aux
salariés et aux employeurs de pente et
de se prononcer sur un litige et je
crois que quand on a cette opportunité
de pouvoir il ay eu vrai il faut y aller
puis la voix vous vous considérez que ça
procède du dialogue social c'est ça ça
procède fortement dialogue social parce
qu'il ya un aspect des prud'hommes qui
pour moi très important qu'est la
conciliation où on essaie de faire que
les parties qui sont concernées par le
litige essaie de trouver un point
d'accord et c'est important et le
dernier c'est que les conseillers du
collège employeurs m'ont demandé des
candidats alors effectivement donc que
j'ai dit qu'il y a
cinq sections en tout donc activités
diverses agriculture commerce industrie
et encadrement voilà et chacun chaque
section donc à ses élus voilà on le
rappelle alors le fait que vous soyez
alors vous êtes du syndicat du medef on
le rappelle le syndicat patronal comme
on dit pour résumer en français le fait
que vous soyez membre
cependant de la commission sociale du du
medef martinique est ce que ce serait
gage d'un relief particulier pour votre
mandature qui parle musique particulier
peut-être pas mais mais par contre que
souligné et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure cette volonté qu'a le medef de
participer de construire et de
consolider le dialogue social sur le
territoire et donc oui ce côté membre de
la commission sociale permet de de de
travailler encore mieux avec puisque
vous l'avez dit on est en paritarisme
il y a donc des représentants de
syndicats salariés et plus on a des
zones de dialogues et des changes
mieux on construit en co construit ce
dialogue nécessaire à la pérennité des
entreprises martiniquaises
alors votre accession à la présidence du
conseil prud'homal ici intervient dans
un contexte particulier on sait la crise
sanitaire la crise y est donc au
coronavirus alors qu'elle ait fait
justement a eu cette crise ces derniers
mois sur le rythme de fonctionnement du
conseil prud'homal ici alors déjà on a
dû faire ce qu'on appelle un plan de
continuité d'activité pour qu'on puisse
adapter justement le fonctionnement du
conseil des prud'hommes à la crise
sanitaire donc c'est un point positif
c'est plus qu'on a pu modifier nos
fonctionnements pour nous adapter à la
réalité de ceux de cette crise notamment
sur les 1 certains nombres de respect
des gestes-barrières aujourd'hui en
comme vous même dans le studio comprend
des dispositions
on a adapté les audiences par exemple on
a pendant la crise sanitaire donc puis
on est généralement quatre en audience
au tribunal des prud'hommes pour pouvoir
assurer le respect des rites de
barrières mais également tenir tenir
compte du fait que nous étions amenés à
à faire du télétravail nous avons réduit
ses compositions à 2 alors vous avez dû
vous adapté pour les audiences mais est
ce que le nombre d'audiences a connu une
baisse alors oui ou premier confinement
puisqu'on a eu zéro saisine était
bloquée et et on a eu à contrario au
deuxième semestre une augmentation en
2020 du nombre de saisines puisque mais
globalement on a quand même eu le même
nombre de saisines entre 2020 et 2010 et
dont vous avez pu rattraper c'est resté
à s'équilibrer
on a bu 25-20 beaucoup de dossiers à
votre 1 p parce que le bon côté j'allais
dire du confinement c'est que les
conseillers ont pu rattraper sur la
rédaction des jugements
le délai est donc par rapport à ça on a
pu réduire notre délai de rendu de
décision aujourd'hui de 15 9 mois
atteint 12,4 pour avoir une idée sont
entrés trop dans les détails
en moyenne c'est combien d'affaires que
vous avez à gérer sur une année un peu
moins de 800 à fait d'accord alors est
ce qu'il y a des dossiers des affaires
qui sont arrivés ces derniers temps en
lien justement avec ce contexte
particulier je pense par exemple à des
dossiers qui seraient liées à du
télétravail mal mises en oeuvre ou que
ce soit l'employeur ou l'employé
s'estime lésé vous voyez où que les
choses n'ont pas été faites dans les
règles
et puis peut-être des licenciements
aussi abusif peut-être alors pas peuvent
pas vous voyez ces patrons qui pourrait
profiter d'un effet d'aubaine à redire
on n'a pas encore de dossiers j'allais
dire spécifiquement liée à la crise on a
eu les mêmes et c'est pas significatif
peut-être que trois 3 4 dossiers liés à
des contextes comme ceux que vous avez
précisé sur des problèmes de rupture du
contrat de travail ou peut-être que des
foyers dépendent le procédure de
procédure mais pour le moment ni sur les
effets du télétravail ni sur les
conséquences j'allais dire
de quiconque qui ont été mises en place
dans l'entreprise du fait de leurs
crises sanitaires n'ont généré
d'affaires particulière une telle qu'on
en verra en 2021 ah oui parce qu'il faut
rappeler que l'action du conseil des
prud'hommes vous y faisait allusion au
tout début d'entretien c'est que bon
c'est une juridiction de premier degré
effectivement et donc il est chargé de
régler les litiges nés à l'occasion de
l'exécution de mauvaise foi du contrat
de travail ou de la rupture de ce
contrat entre employeurs et salariés de
droit privé
et puis bon voilà ce que disait de les
exemples les plus fréquents c'est les
cas de licenciement ou de rupture
conventionnelle abusive
est-ce que ça a eu un impact aussi sur
les formations parce que je sais que le
conseil des prud'hommes dispense des
formations pour donc ses membres tout à
fait alors bien sûr comme présentiel on
a on n'a pas eu de formation sur cette
période mais on a la chance avec l'école
nationale de la magistrature d'avoir eu
d'avoir mis en place des formations à
distance qui permet aux qui a permis aux
conseillers aux juges prud'homaux
pendant l'appel de confinement de
pouvoir revenir sur un certain nombre de
da qui est de savoir pour mieux vrai
dans le cas de leur mandat très bien
hervé honoré nouveau président du
conseil des prud'hommes de martinique on
arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
entretien
ce que je voulais vous demander c'est
est-ce que du coup vous vous intéressez
pas ce que c'est ça fera partie de votre
mandat à cette réforme qui doit entrer
en vigueur en 2023 au 1er janvier de
ville 2023 qui prévoit une bonification
du nombre de conseillers
parce que on tiendra compte de
l'évolution justement du volume de
contentieux traités par chaque
juridiction
alors qu'est ce qui est à temps alors de
ce point de vue alors nous avons nous
serons là que la juridiction de
fort-de-france a concerné puisque on va
passer de 60 4 conseillers prud'homaux à
80 et je profite de votre en
augmentation en augmentation et jeu et
je profite pour me ainsi les les le
parquet
les chefs de cour le procureur et la
vision et la présidente qui ont pris en
compte nos suggestions pour que ce
nombre soit adaptée aux sections parce
que comme vous l'avait dit il ya
plusieurs sections et en fonction du
nombre de dossiers par section il faut
adapter on n'a pas beaucoup d'affaires
l'agriculture donc c'est pas la peine
d'augmenter le nombre de conseillers à
l'agriculture par contre on commerce on
a beaucoup de conseillers d'affaires
donc il faut augmenter le nombre donc
oui nous sommes tous concernés et c'est
pour ça que dans notre mandat dans mon
mandat je vais faire la promotion du
travail fait par les cons les juges
prud'homaux pour susciter des vocations
pour qu'on ait les 80 conseillers en
2023 bon ben vous aurez l'occasion de
revenir justement pour cela certainement
merci hervé honoré
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions et
puis un bon mandat à la tête du conseil
des prud'hommes pour quelques temps ici
merci
[Musique]